not anymore it doesn't make sense of
course doesn't make any
sense even she was a Christian she was a
Muslim now CU Christian doesn't make any
sense you understand so about you
believe in God I believe there a there's
pure existence that's why I as there's
an unced cause there is something that
creates the universe we could say that
yeah obvious I mean
yeah course and that's the Quan the
quranic sty Allah utilized his creation
to establish that there is a Creator
should alone like I was speaking two
days ago to this individual from Spain
become Muslim after two hours discussion
with him but I him one thing that either
this universe was created by a blind
matter blind matter organized itself or
this universe was created by Creator
there knowledge power ability how do you
know is that the first one which you
inan the second one which is the creator
that possess knowledge and power and
wisdom because we can see the effects of
the Creator's wisdom and his power and
the knowledge within his creation like
you can see there order you understand
like today is Sunday tomorrow is Monday
the day after is Tuesday how do we know
that sun setting and sun rises you
understand this
cor so Sun alhamdulillah likewise look
we have a nose next to our M before you
eat what you do smell food you have
eyebrows above your eyes why because the
sweat contains a Sal if it keeps going
to your eyes will damage it you have a
teeth in your mouth you understand so
this impossible illogical
irrational thank you very that's what
the Quran said the ver Arabic I recite
translate the meaning of it Allah
said Allah said within the creation of
the heavens and Earth and the alteration
of the day and night it is a sign for
people understand sound reasoning sound
intellect that like I said impossible
for this universe to or for this
universe to come without any Creator if
is the case therefore dictate the
Creator is this knowledge and wisdom
will not create us without any purpose
do you agree with that without so every
part of your party has a
purpose okay so therefore what is our
what is our purpose as a whole now let
me just give you an analogy imagine I'm
the first person to make a phone imagine
there's no one made phone before me I'm
the first person to make a phone now in
order for you to know what is the
purpose of the phone who should you go
to that's it thank you very much so Ro
dictate now in order for us to know what
is our purpose in this life roate we go
back to the Creator that's why we say
based upon the Creator's wisdom and
mercy and Justice he CH people amongst
us to send them as a prophet Messengers
to teach us about our purpose in this
life generally speaking you know sorry
there's too many mic no understand
generally speaking thank you generally
speaking we have something called f in
Arabic called f which is natural
inclination like naturally you know I
should not oppress a child naturally you
know I should be good to my mother
naturally you know I should be good to
my sister to my father to my wife to my
neighbors however we need a detailed
information how to run out like for
example or how to do it for example I
need to be good to my mother and my
father but who deserves my companionship
for Islam comes in your mother who
called you for 9 months is your mother
it's not your father who wakes up every
night to change your knp when you are
very young child is your mother
understand who's bre with you your
mother now based upon the Creator wisdom
and Revelation that the mother has more
rights so
now someone's fall what happened here
man so now what we say to you like you
came from a Christian background we
believe in Jesus us we believe in Moses
Oh yes most respectful religion
to anything they say disgusting things
no I think I think Islam is is
definitely the religion of respect and
100% that also is a religion that which
goes in line with our natural internal I
know that with our sound intellect you
understand for example to make something
very what distinguish Islam from any
religion Islam came to preserve five
things which we call Universal necessity
okay five things the first Islam came to
preserve religion what does that mean in
Islam not following the true God will
have an evil impact on us and on our
society so worshiping the true God and
following the true teaching of God is
very important that's why Islam will not
allow to pray to anyone except Allah the
creator of everything exactly the second
thing Islam came to preserve intellect
that's why Islam alcohol and drugs
forbidden yeah third Islam came to
preserve wealth like was the alcohol
forbidden because they got drunk while
praying or was it no no because because
there's a lot of harm in it there is
harm in it you know but however at the
time Muhammad from the wisdom of the
Creator the way Allah made it and lo is
stage by stage I see first thing don't
come close to the prayer when you
are drunkness state of junk yeah so it
was step by step and this is to show you
the wisdom of the Creator understand but
yes has more harm than good okay so
Islam came to preserve the intellect
that's why alcohol and drugs forbidden
Islam came to preserve wealth that's why
dumbing and interest is forbidden Islam
came to preserve life that's why killing
people unjustly committing suicide is
forbidden Islam came to preserve family
lineage that's why fornication adultery
is forbidden these five things Islam
came to preserve if we do preserve them
correctly we'll have good Society what
is the opposite alcohol alcohol is bad
for us individually and collectively
Gamblin is bad for us individually and
collectively interest which is Banks is
best for us individually and
collectively uh uh fornication likewise
destroy families destroy societies you
understand so now these viices alcohol
uh drugs and other things there is some
people do benefit from them who are they
those who are in power that's why
genuinely speaking that's it majority of
those who are very hostile to Islam
those who are in power because they look
at Islam as a thre for their business
Islam they see Islam is good for people
but because they have evil desires and
evil intention so they utilize their
wealth through the media to make Islam
look bad even though I just have
explained to you Islam is good for us
individually and the question you should
ask yourself how a man that existed
1,400 years ago Prophet Muhammad who
couldn't read and write how he came with
is a perfect way life because he was a
messenger of the most high and there's
many prophecies that Prophet Muhammad
said we can see right now for example
Muhammad said it will come a time when
you see the barefood Arab men the Arabs
they will start competing in building to
building remember Prophet Muhammad
existed 1,400 years ago there was no
there was any indication that do it let
me ask you where is the tallest building
in the world uh duai Dubai
50 years ago Dubai was a pure desert let
Al 1,400 years ago so how is the mercy
of God and Allah is so powerful the same
thing that is a mercy he can turn it to
punishment by destroying the the evil
ones so here is how he knew the
messenger of God you understand
have give me that let the phone have
some mercy
as it's our guest let him have it Hood
so say come come come inside come come
come come close you have it for yourself
for
me got jacket have no
jacket so what I was going to say to
you there's many prophecies like another
prophecy you know interest interest yeah
which is like you know it's interest
yeah when you charge more when someone's
in need of help instead of helping him
utilize his need to manipulate him yes
to manipulate him so Prophet Muhammad
said there will come a time when
interest will become
widespread even if you are not involved
directly will affect you now if you open
a bank account and you tell them listen
I don't want interest in my bank account
they still use your money for interest
again of course no how come again how a
man that existed 1,400 years ago knowing
about something which you can see right
now let me give you an analogy imag I
said to you look bro I'm I'm multi
millionaire and I'm really enjoying the
discussion I'm going to give you a gift
I don't want nothing from you I'm going
to give you a gift I'm going to give you
2 million pound as a gift what would you
say to me at least would you remember me
all the time would you remember million
it's a big money bro I will give you 2
million on a condition there's condition
Now give me your two eyes would you do
that no go you see the way I stra way
why because your eye is more valuable
than anything else so the question
should ask yourself when grateful and
remember who gave you eyes for free EX
no for get money I know
that but now I give you another analogy
if you want to buy a gift for your
mother will you buy a gift that your
love or your mother love likewise if you
want to be grateful you want appreciate
worship the Creator you should worship
him the way he loves not the way we love
that's why God sent Jesus Moses Abraham
now the last of them Prophet Muhammad so
now if you want to worship the Creator
the way the Creator want to worship him
then should do it according to the
teaching of the Prophet muhamad so what
I would say to you does it make sense to
you I said so far yeah it does it does
to I give you open invitation no force
in nothing my question to you why don't
why don't you become Muslim it make
sense to you yeah okay let me I'll just
say a few things about why I wasn't
Christian I want to ask a few questions
about Islam before I explain why no
problem go ahead so the number one
reason I wasn't Christian was because
the Bible says God has unconditional
love and the the Eternal Heaven eternal
hell but the only way to get to that is
if you believe in him and if you love
him now if I'm if I'm not mistaken
there's no unconditional love in Islam
right no no there
is no no there's unconditional love
there's condition condition
condition they put the condition on it
and they're saying
unconditional even I mention that you
you're right because they say God loves
everyone but God who loves everyone is
going to punish the same people that he
loves eternally make any sense to me so
yes Islam because God's love is very
special you cannot be raping woman
killing innocent people no no no no you
know so in Islam God's love is very
special how you get God's love by
following his
teaching no good so my my question for
you is Islam there
something that's right so I don't mean
you but God said everything that will
happen and everything that won't happen
yes by that Essence I kind of see
conflict with free and free world no it
doesn't let me explain to you what is
the Islam Islam means Allah knew
everything because he has a knowledge
okay so Allah knew that you going to do
and I'm going to I'm going to do okay
the other uh the other category of other
Allah has written everything in in The
Preserve tablet which we all right the
other thing Allah the creator of
everything Allah creat going to create
everything all right likewise Allah
wield it we me Allah allow it so now let
us see if the goes against the our free
doesn't because why not if I say to you
brother look don't go to Central London
in central London there's there's a lot
of shooting going on there now you say
you know what Allah I'm going to be kill
I'm going to go your out respect this
person is foolish so if you take the
option to not go there Allah knows it
yeah so there's no conflict or
contradiction between the Allah KN
everything and you taking the action
I'll give you example to Allah is the
most just to Allah will not judge us
based upon something that we do not do
based upon our Free Will and we have to
have a knowledge now watch this in Islam
if I'm sleeping and I start cursing
Allah cursing Allah insulting Allah
sleep Allah will not hold me
accountable if there is no free will
Allah will hold me accountable all the
time so what Allah is distinguishing me
through sleeping and we cuz when I'm
sleeping my conscious not there yeah
even if you are even if you have a will
imagine now a new Muslim he's a new
Muslim he has a free will everything he
start drinking alcohol but does no
alcohol is Haram Allah will not judge
him because even though he has a free
will no one forced him okay so no one
forced him but because he didn't have
the knowledge that shows you Allah is
the most just so of Allah now in order
for you and me to know what Allah has
made other for us we have to do what
take an action you see and the action is
based upon your free will is for example
I cannot be sitting down yeah you know
there's no work for me it was I said get
up and go look for work you understand
so now in order for in order for me to
know what Allah has written for me in
terms of my provision what the money I'm
going to make I have to do what take the
action and the action is based upon what
it's based upon my ability and My Free
Will and my intent Allah create them but
you choose to act upon
them my inial I Wasing say God has the
full knowledge right that's right and we
know that God's not subjected to time so
God's outside time cuz he's the Creator
when we speak about
time our time yes creat time time is
notti go
ahead we know that God just exists and
then we came into existence God create
us yes I don't know
but I know in Christianity God God could
see what was going on and the argument
is God's for knowledge knew our choices
us to do that I don't know if that's
understand that because no no Islam
correct me if I'm wrong you saying Allah
has a knowledge perfect knowledge and he
knows everything okay and he create us
even though he knows what is our destiny
correct that's what I'm saying so I'm
saying we have God's full knowledge and
we created by us for knowledge yes and
if he knows the decision I'm going to
take yes that kind of emphasize that the
decision's already been brought into
existence so it's not really being made
no no that decision would take that
decision will come to existence when you
act upon that knowledge which Allah have
but if he creates all things how can I
create the existence no no you taking
the action for example Allah created you
right and within you is ability yes not
I have ability to walk but I don't want
to walk am I going to walk what want to
walk you I'm going to walk now I want to
walk but I don't have the ability I'm I
going to walk no in order for me to take
an action I have to have ability and
intent okay so the action now I'm going
to take now is based upon my choice you
understand so therefore for example now
and this argument which been used by one
of the Christians at the time of one SCH
called so this Christian said to I use
it against yeah the chrisan the Muslim
in dcus so he said to what Allah is to
judge me to be because I'm a Christian
when Allah already knew I'm going to be
a Christian so said to him hang on if
someone come to rob you and take you
stuff I would you be happy if he said
listen do not complain to the police
because Allah has written that I'm going
to rob you or you're going to complain
to the police you understand of course
so so even you if someone comes to take
your phone and you say you know Allah
has the Creed for me to take your phone
don't do nothing said no no no you I
have to defend myself so in our real
life we know that we have a free will so
our free will our our action is based
upon our choice Allah allow it to happen
because already Allah told us he will
put us through a test if Allah stop you
to do Har and he stops everyone what is
the point of the test Allah put us a
test us also for Allah to implement his
names and attributes you understand I've
got two questions is that
clear not comp the two questions about
that was if God knows the outcome of
that test what's the point of test but
you don't know the T no I don't but the
point is he knows what is to implement
his name attribute to implement his
attribute of Mercy the attribute of
mighty the attribute of anger the
attribute of Love however Allah wants to
implement it based upon Justice you
understand the thing about the Free Will
things so if today God knows I'm going
to talk to you yeah and he knew that
yesterday and this for knowledge
yesterday said I'll come and talk to you
okay can I really choose not to talk to
you in my time in the past that means
God's for would have been wrong you see
what you're doing you are conflicting
between okay Allah knew you doesn't mean
Allah forced you no I know but so
yesterday yesterday was my present so
right now it's my past but yesterday if
I'm living it be my
present Allah knew talk to me yes yeah
yes by but why Allah knew is because he
knew the actually going to taste which
is going to be based upon your free will
but that's the future the future that
means go into existence that's why he
can see no no Allah knows it that's why
there two Allah knowledge there
is the knowledge of the Unseen and the
knowledge of the seen so in order for
the knowledge of Allah seen to come into
existence you have take the
action so so now like I said to you for
example now you're talking about uh uh
Allah knowing that you com to talk to me
but Allah knows it because Allah knows
everything but Allah knows that you
going to take that choice based upon
your free will you understand so like
you know many people have spoke to to
them about concerning other I don't know
how they think there's contradiction
between the two I can see
that she husband CHR she need husband
you know any crazy
husband so there's no also I say to you
also we have to also be careful from the
Satan cuz they good ask questions no
problem like that's what Islam teach us
you know
Allah the cousin of the messenger of
Allah when he when he had a lot of
knowledge and he gained a lot of
knowledge he was asked how you have a
lot of knowledge he
said asking too many questions likewise
mizing however Satan sometimes will try
to do anything to stop us from accepting
God and following him and Satan will put
it quote unquote as logical arguments
you see what I'm saying because this
argument is not logical it's not
rational you understand because now like
I said to you no one will be sitting at
home not doing nothing and they say it's
a cre for me to not work or someone say
you know what I want to have a child
okay brother get married Allah de for me
to have a child in order for you to know
what Allah de for you you have to do
what take the action get married
understand so you take action getting
married did you get married based upon
your own choice or Allah forced you my
my own choice your own choice
that's face value so to me with my
it's me interacting with that's what I'm
saying if my actions is the same as
God's SP knowledge that came before me
I'm just aligning myself with what God
for you and by that premises if I'm if
if he came before me cuz he just exists
and I was go into existence and my
actions are aligning what he he knew was
going to happen and by that premises I'm
just playing it out you know it's like
the movie with the author no you're not
playing it out I mean like like I said
if you say you're playing so now okay if
someone says I'm going to rob you Allah
a knowledge that you're going to do
nothing so don't do nothing would you
accept that no okay but he's going to
say you no no just play out that Allah
already knew going to do nothing listen
carefully to show you before it's going
to it's going to tell you Allah knew
that you're going to do nothing don't do
nothing are you going to listen to him
or you going to do an action not do the
action that's it so so don't use this
argument
from what what I meant was it's not that
it's the guy that says Allah said it's
Allah already knew that I was going to
yeah of course everything's going to
happen but Allah mean Allah knows it you
see what I'm saying Allah allow it Allah
will yeah there's no problem with that
yeah so what what I meant was what I
meant was if Allah knew that in my
future you I wasn't I wasn't going to
like if you were going to rob me you
won't if you were and God knew a week
ago that I wasn't going to do nothing
when that time comes I cannot choose to
do something cuz that meant doing my you
know my present back then
it means his his no no no no Allah knew
it why Allah knew it because Allah knew
that you're going to choose exactly I'm
aligning with the SP yeah so but there's
no contradiction between you choose it
Allah knowing
it no but Allah KN Allah full knowledge
that you going to do something or not
that is not about forcing you has about
forcing you it's about me Allah knowing
which action you going to take you
understand you understand my point now
so Allah knowing that which action
you're going to take take doesn't not
mean it's forc on you otherwise there
will be chaos in the universe otherwise
I'll be killing people if they told me
Allah knows it therefore he forc me no
the judge will accept it the police
officer will accept it your own family
will accept it that's what I'm saying so
therefore this argument is been used by
S it's a s argument which is what is it
I'm
against using it have respect that's I'm
to clarify no no of course what I'm
saying sometimes we use an AR of a sub
without us realizing cuz I can see
you're a good
guy I can see you're a nice guy coming
with sincerity only person but what I'm
saying sometimes what will happen to us
we start using an argument which is
without us realizing you understand so
because your argument correct I'm wrong
because Allah knows it therefore it's
forcing me are you saying that kind of
indirectly what I'm saying isect if he
can if he can foresee something in the
future yes
cuz we know that God can't see things
that don't exist right can hear knows
everything yes yeah but but when you
mean everything that would include like
a square circle cuz it's not a thing to
exist to begin with yeah a it's a
paradox yeah so to see something in the
future that I haven't brought you or to
see something I will do can already see
already kind of shows that it already
exist we don't say to see we say Allah
knows it knows know he knows something
that it must already exist he can't know
a square circle because it cannot exist
so if you can he knows something that
that will Exist by that premises I'm
just playing it out I'm just it's just
unknown becoming no you yeah but we not
playing it out because how do you know
that Allah knew that you're going to
take the action you don't know so what
I'm saying that Allah KN to us we don't
know it that's it so so what I'm saying
you taking the action Allah knows or not
or your action is in line with Allah's
knowledge doesn't mean Allah yes 100%
your action is going to be going to be
with Allah in line with Allah not
but doesn't mean Allah for you okay now
he came before us we're aligning
ourselves with his knowledge okay if you
accept that me can I give an answer real
quick just if you accept that if I'm
going to force you are you going to hold
me
accountable if you force me to do if I'm
going to rob you so if I'm going to rob
you are you going to hold me accountable
yeah why but God forc me I have no
choice then you're saying it's compelled
you're saying it's compelled yeah but
then but by that premises we're not
saying that what God is saying is wrong
no not say wrong this our understanding
is wrong yeah you understand so what my
point here is that's
what said said any human being in
reality CU this argument I'm telling you
you are using it without realizing this
argument is is is argument people use it
to look for a way out to accept God turn
away from God even I don't believe
you're doing that inshallah but this the
point here is that this argument is is
inval argument you know why cuz if we
accept that Allah is forcing me you
canot hold me accountable I can't be
doing whatever I like if I go to the
judge I go to the judge say is a judge
you can you can force me you cannot put
me in prison why I was not doing it
that's why Islam sorry that's why is
that if someone force you to do
something Allah want to hold you
comfortable okay so if Allah forcing you
why come if someone forcing you that
that person who's forcing you he's going
tell you Allah forc me that's you
there's no connection connection between
Allah knowing something you taking
action only why is that Allah's
knowledge is perfect you
taking you taking an action you taking
action okay you taking action Allah
knows it that's it I going tell you
something be honest with yourself if you
stand up before Allah the almighty on
the day of judgment and he say why do
you accept the
truth I said what would be your argument
yeah so why so why I did not choose
Islam yes yes i' say it was number one
about the and number two is the idea of
Faith so there the faith thing about how
we're believeing I don't think be saying
that I don't okay if I was in judgment
and I see the almighty no I was wrong
but why you wrong you said you have good
you have an argument no no what I'm
saying is he saying didn't do this
argument is valid or is not valid you
argument is it valid or not valid what
you mean the argument if Allah knows no
the argument just a probability is it
valid
argum so you saying that Allah knowing
something therefore Allah is forced to
do something even say indirectly this
argument you saying you think it's
valid about Islam I I wouldn't
say the point about the yeah yeah good
the point about the we
mydy God alhamdulillah
the point about the
predestination was you take them I'll
have
my get
get open up for and you know Sor just I
something you know who the first person
use this
argument yeah Satan used and
guess he said you forc
me but you see because arrogance but
Adam when Adam Comm he never used way he
said he said I make so much Allah okay
you can you can use after but Allah
forced you happen to me Allah Allah forc
you so my point here is that the first
person to use this argument is a Satan
according to the Quran according to the
Bible as well the Satan is the first
person to use the argument of Al that he
did an action because God forc him okay
you see what I'm saying so Satan is an
enemy of God but you see when you humble
yourself and you know that listen my
free will I have a free will and is is
something which observable something
which is clear cut you understand but
what I can see out respect now we are
utilizing it against God when you know
in the reality doesn't not exist I mean
it's not valid in the reality it's not
valid cuz if you believe is valid
therefore no one should be in prison
they have to be consistent that's why
you know there's no need for court
there's no need to have courts yeah
there's no courts here they being
compelled people and and Muslims if they
accept that we're all pression we can
say so my thought why am I going to help
no but predestined doesn't not
necessitate God is forcing you that's
have understand like if I know which
action you're going to take that's
predestination that's God God saying
okay you're going to believe in me
you're going to do this you're going to
do that but it's based upon his okay
okay based upon his perfect knowledge
he's going to tell you what you're going
to do but is the action based upon your
own choice based on what he was what he
thought what he fores no no listen
carefully Creator okay no listen
carefully okay the Creator having a
perfect knowledge you know why he has
perfect knowledge which you're going to
take but your action is based upon your
free will okay so we haven't existed but
before we existed God can foresee what
his is going to do he knows everything
so he's creating people to do what that
for knowledge is no he didn't create
what that's the trick here are you
saying he created them to force them to
do it or he created them because they're
going to take some action which is he's
going to one of God's purpose of
creating us to implement name attribute
so he know this person going to do evil
this person is going to do good so if
you do good based on your own choice if
you do Evil based upon your own choice
but both you you're going to see my uh
my mercy and my love or my anger and
mighty which is based upon Justice you
understand so that's what that's what I
would say to you look when you say that
God is forcing us logically doesn't make
any sense because like I said to you if
God forcing us how come Allah is is not
going to judge me when I'm cursing him
when I'm sleeping why if he's forcing me
all the time if it's if that's why I
said we can't say God forcing us to have
religion by that it's not you cannot you
cannot say what but what I'm saying is I
agree with you we can't say you know
there's Islam and that kind of stuff but
at the same time God has for God forced
us to do so you agree with me God is not
forcing us no no I'm saying by by by
that premises by that premises having a
full knowledge there is forcing us what
I'm saying in a way what I'm trying to
as as as a religious person you can't
say God's God would force me to do so
because by that is that would mean the
religion is wrong because the religion
says side sorry side in
reality we know we're not forced to in I
know if I'm going to get married to a
woman I'm going to say I'm going to
marry any woman I know I'm going to look
for woman that I'm going to be happy
with but if I have no choice I should be
Mar the first I'm going to look into the
fact I'm choosing yes that show I have a
choice understand they have a will so in
reality atheist even when when some
atheists are mocking his name um I think
lence CR is's the one who said there's
no free will they were moing him because
in reality you can see you have a free
will Allah knowing something doesn't not
negate or doesn't not go and gu you
taking your action by your own choice
otherwise there will be no courts no
police stations there will be no one
judged I can rob you and I said listen
you cannot judge me but no one accept
that cuz we don't know you have a feet
whe for example if someone if a blind
man walk in and he hits me with a stick
okay he with his stick are you going to
say he done in purpose no unless unless
he knew I was there unless so you
differentiate between purpose mean he
done it based upon his will he knew
understand so we can see in reality
there is action which is occurred by
people Free Will and and and uh and
choose it and some actions which is they
have no control over for example if I
get sick that's purely from God okay I
have no uh uh my Free Will has nothing
to do with it so is Allah now to show
you Allah Justice again listen carefully
if I get sick and I cannot pray in the
most would Allah judge me for not
praying in the most he will't judge me
no but if Allah is forcing me all the
time so what Allah is distinguishing me
being sick and he excusing me because
because a sickness is not something
which I control I have control over it's
beyond me but now if I have ability and
Free Will and and and I hear then call
and I go to MOS if I believe it's
obligatory I have to go to MOS Allah
will hold me accountable so we can see
Allah's wisdom and we can see if Allah
is not just he will not differentiate
between our actions the fact he
differentiate between our actions which
is based upon purely our own choice and
other actions which purely we have no
control
over clear so far yeah I I get what you
thinking I get your position
[Music]
so you might you might need to Define
what sort of attributes you
expect to have including Justice right
so if you if you're a Believer would you
agree that this being should be just and
fair yeah
so that's right you know what I mean if
if you if you believe that one of his
attributes to be just and fair then
definitely you have a free well
otherwise would be can I ask you another
question about so do you accept God is
just we can
say and it's clear so far yeah yeah I
see your points the next question I want
to ask uh I'm coming here to learn I I
don't be on YouTube stupid
atheist you're atheist you believe in
god well yeah I believe is a yeah so I
was trying to say was I going to say I
can definitely say it's not Christianity
I can say that for sure what you mean
it's not Christianity I can say it's not
a Christian because I know there's
Christian is in Jesus that's iesus make
sense so the next question is if God
wanted to make
himself if if God wanted to make himself
known to to all of his creation why did
he go
through you know what's happening now
you want to dictate to God what he
should do yeah the argument AB okay I
mean back then back then no but what
have again this is this is what boils
down to it's like
I'm going to answer it but what you do
when you're trying to dictate to God
what he should do for example if God so
you want God to go through what but what
I'm saying is back then yes if God
wanted to make himself known to all
creation yes like I want to if I was God
I and I the purpose was to show myself
to all of my creation yeah why just why
not just show why not go to one person
the brother good point about go to be
just who has the perfect wisdom perfect
knowledge you or God God so therefore
who should know how to deal with
creation you or God
God what I'm saying how come wouldn't it
be better to go directly to the question
to begin with is wrong everyone saying
the question to begin with is wrong you
know why it's wrong why because you just
admitted and accepted that you are God
has a perfect knowledge and a perfect
wisdom we have imperfect knowledge
imperfect wi the question is it logical
for me as a person who has a very tiny
knowledge and very wisdom to ask how God
should deal with creation who has a
perfect wisdom perfect
knowledge you understand so therefore
the question to begin with is wrong
again go back to my point this is is H
it that's why I was wearing jacket I
left it home that's why when I said
about sry this argument through the
history is when you go back when you try
to question when you look into it deeply
it goes back to uh uh sry just looking
for anything to to to what call it it's
like semantics semantic there's a ter
for it which is is a sry which is to
turn away from God or to look for
anything to to to reject God or to try
to dictate what God should do but with a
person sorry as a believer in God I you
know God has a perfect knowledge perfect
wisdom it's illogical for me try to
dictate to God how he should do it yeah
and he's the wise
what
[Music]
God you can read through the text and
read should be in
that I mean so you take yourself
one the attri
of outside even if if you're going
outside of the religion box
but you
know you know what's happen is sometimes
a agnostic or people start to question
God what they do they take one attri of
God and they isolated from the other
attributes of God and they put a
question upon it yeah okay for example
what earlier you did you took the the
attribute of God of knowledge and you
build question upon it but the brother
mention good about but you agree that
God is is just so if he's just therefore
he will not even if he knew something
going to happen he will not force you to
do something then punish you yeah
exactly yeah that's why that's why I
said my my my basis would be saying
Islam is because if he's forcing us then
we're not really the wrong he would so I
heing you exactly that's what I me
that's I that's why
I I thought you meant if God knew
something is going to occur therefore
somehow he's forcing us
that is not the case like I said because
we have to agree that God is perfect has
a perfect wisdom perfect Justice perfect
Mercy therefore the perfect go the god
with the perfect Justice he will not
oppress his creation and Allah
Quran your lord does not oppress his
creation Allah said Allah Allah said in
the
Quran Allah said
we never oppress them they oppress
themselves you cause the rain to come
there's
noain from God when I talk nothing and
then God showing
us
one show your signs
bro like I it's good to ask question so
yeah it's good but when when I was about
sometimes you are using sry uh equ which
is sry he not trying to disrespect you
something I can said something use
sometimes certain things without us
realizing we are falling into something
which we are against yeah you understand
like sometimes people use a liberal
argument and they say we against
liberalism why is using liberal argument
you with me yeah yeah you have another
question I like the way you know we're
talking CU I like to think of myself as
a truth Sinker a truth seeker seeker s
it's good think the truth anyway Tru the
truth a truth seeker seeker so I don't
like to look at something and say no
that's wrong without me going to ask
questions I I live to chrity I ask
questions I got my answer it's noan I
knew that when you know the further you
think about it I need to go about I
already know
there's music har before that before ask
question Allah know Allah thean you know
about thinking Allah
always not
think not
reflect so Allah mentioned these verses
that's why I was speaking to you earlier
on about what prophet Muhammad came with
the five Universal necessity to preserve
one of them is the intellect intellect
is one of the faculties that faculty
that we utilize to carry out Allah's
obligation upon us so if someone's
insane Allah will not hold him
accountable for doing you see Allah is
what just otherwise he will hold us
every accountable if it's for in us or
if we have no choice okay or if it's for
has to do
something is very important but the
which has to be also can be dangerous as
well if you don't not use in the way
which God wants to use it like you know
there's many philos out there it's sub
no is a test from God either you're
going to utilize it in a way which
pleases God or you're going to figure
too smart and how how I am for example
I'm a professor in Oxford University I'm
going to follow a man that lives in the
middle of desert how have qualification
so what happened your become became a TR
upon you to prevent you the truth you
understand so you have other
questions so what I was going to say to
you like no about Prophet Muhammad's
prophecy about the Miracles about even
the Quran you know even me want speak to
you about example of giving 2 million
about the eyes you you would thank me
straight away you remember me understand
so what I would say to you so far that's
Islam makes make sense to you a bit more
sense yeah I need to go and and DW upon
it you know cuz the thing is these
things it's not like a quick
conversation no no of course of course
sometimes you have to think I mean some
people to be honest with you I've been
doing this for the last 15 years all
right and just two days ago Friday three
people become Muslims so sometimes
alhamdulillah
Allah sometimes what happen some people
accept the TRU it's clear to them and
make sense to you know it goes in line
with my natural ination and sometimes
people need some time you know they need
some some time to think about it but one
thing you have to bear in mind that you
and I we not promised him tomorrow we
can live this life any time that's what
Allah said Allah said I can die when I
leave I can die
said haste rush into doing good things
because Satan always will try to stop us
from accepting the truth even in the
Quran there's stor when the the the the
the the enemies of the prophets and
Messengers were mocking the prophet's
followers because they accept the truth
so quick but Allah me as a virtue if is
clear to you and it makes sense I accept
away why I'm going to delay it
understand
aldah thank you very much when go home
raise your hand to the creator of
everything say all the creator of
everything trth